ladies and gentlemen one of the most
exciting words in show business
share
thank you the nominees for Best Picture
are the accidental tourist Lawrence
Kasdan Charles oaken and Michael Grillo
producers dangerous liaison Norma Heyman
and Hank moon gene producers Mississippi
Burning
Fredrik Zola and Robert F cause berry
producers Raymond Mark Johnson producer
and working girl
Douglas wick producer and the winner is
Rain Man Mark Johnson
I've been told for the past five weeks
and maybe I should prepare for this I
can't be prepared for this moment
there's so many people Rain Man belongs
to a lot of people let me start with Ron
bass and Barrymore oh who wrote a
wonderful script Peter Guber and John
Peters for being exactly what executive
producers should be in supporting us all
the way to Gayle new tricks for
supporting me I'd like to thank boy
Michael Ovitz and Rose Elise wetland for
standing by this for weeks weeks and
years I'd like to thank Dustin and Tom
and a wonderful studio that really
doesn't exist anymore Lee rich Tony
Thermopolis and Roger Birnbaum who
reunited artists and really exactly what
anybody who want out of a studio and the
producer says that we're not allowed to
we shouldn't really thank our families
we're supposed to wait until we go
backstage and use the payphone but he
doesn't know my family I'd like to thank
my wife Leslie who really stood by me
our two foster children Jack and Rebecca
and boy if I didn't mention my mother
I'd be a dead man
Dorothy King and very Barrington thank
you
we hope you had a good time good night
everybody god bless you
you